thank you for this you'll frighten my
father you are both the victims I can
have one of them find peace
you know if they find out he's here
don't come from let them try
[Music]
hey guys what's up awesome news Marvel
just confirmed they are rolling cameras
on Black Panther they released a whole
bunch of details so let's break it down
they're shooting the movie in South
Korea if you didn't know it's coming out
in February and they have the craziest
most awesome cast ever it's going to be
nuts it's the last film before infinity
war so I'll address all the infinity war
stuff the Infinity Gauntlet the
soulstone but there is a new round of
the Spider Man giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so this picks up
in the moments after Captain America
Civil War so I'll try to address the
Captain America as well as the Bucky the
Avengers and Sandy War stuff but the
teaser synopsis just read to chala who
after the events of Captain America
Civil War returns home to the isolated
technologically advanced African nation
of Wakanda to take his place as king
however when an old enemy reappears on
the radar two challahs metal as king and
black panther is tested when he is drawn
into a conflict that puts the entire
fate of Wakanda in the world at risk so
this is where we get into the villains
they tease the villa's in their kill
monger and ulysses klaw have been
confirmed as villain they won't be the
only antagonists in the movie there'll
be a lot of other people there's a lot
of complex politics in Wakanda that we
haven't seen yet so we'll learn about
the relationships within that nation but
you all remember ulysses klaw from age
of ultron
on this rock I will build my church my
Radian you know it's kind that's great
personal cost it's worth billions now so
are you he had had past encounters with
Wakanda he been branded for stealing
vibranium which Ultron then turned
around and used to make his big drill as
well as vision is going to be coming
back to get more that's probably the
worldwide threat like if he gets his
hands on more of that than he's going to
make weapons it's going to mean trouble
for the rest of the world but testing
him on a more personal level is kill
monger he has a much more personal
relationship with that character kill
monger is the son of someone who was
press-ganged into working for ulysses
klaw in the past therefore his family
was exiled by Black Panthers father his
family became Dishonored outcasts he
vowed revenge against the wakandan
people as well as ulysses klaw went to
the united states to earn a degree from
MIT black panther also went to the
United States to get a degree but he
went to a different college in Berkeley
they might change that for the movie
just to give them some more backstory
together but he becomes one of those
characters to test Black Panthers honor
so Black Panther will face very big
challenges from people like ulysses klaw
in very personal challenges to his reign
from people like kil monger so everybody
wants to take a shot at the king in now
he's King as the synopsis implies right
after Civil War he's effectively king so
he has to go back and deal with all that
now the movie is coming out February
2018 so you have to imagine it's a
couple years after the end of Captain
America Civil War so he's already been
back in Wakanda for a little while he
may have even been bankrolling Captain
America's Secret Avengers that's what
I'm going to call him for now but he
doesn't have the shield and he's not
using the title so technically he's not
Captain America anymore that won't
change til infinity war but in the way
we're getting an Iron Man appearance
during Spider
man we might see some Captain America
Bucky stuff during the Black Panther
movie but they be very very minor
characters because they're just so much
rich history in the black panther comics
that Marvel hasn't touched yet so
they're going to need to spend most of
the time setting that up you can see how
they're doing more crossovers now just
to sort of juice up the pitch of a movie
like hey come see black panther and see
that other characters that you really
really like Captain America so that's
kind of the way that they're sweetening
the pot to get people to go see
spider-man because we know you love Iron
Man so we're going to put them in this
movie so they get a lot of other people
that wouldn't otherwise care about a
spider-man movie the other really
important thing to consider is that
black panther is coming out just a
couple months before Avengers infinity
war so the end of that movie will lead
directly into the opening moments of
infinity war meaning that because we
know Bucky is coming back for infinity
war they'll have to be at least some
Captain America storyline stuff
happening but they could totally push
that to post-credits status like they
don't actually have to hijack any of the
movie if they don't want to for that if
you don't know anything about the rest
of the cast they just have like the
murderers row of talent they have Martin
Freeman who's playing Everett Ross also
from Captain America Civil War he's sort
of the government liaison that deals
with the Wakanda nation Forest
Whitaker's playing a character from the
comics who sort of like the adviser to
the previous Black Panther so he becomes
the wise master that helps advise Black
Panther as he tries to learn how to be
king Danai gurira and Lupita Nyong'o are
both playing Dora mala J they're going
to be so badass they're like Special
Forces military spec ops
just the most badass soldiers in
full-blown tech in vibranium gear that
you could possibly imagine that's why
that Black Widow standoff in Civil War
was so funny black panther himself just
chuckles oh I would love to see this but
we don't have time
move oh you would be moved as
entertaining as that would be you really
think you can find out a certain uh
considerable yeah just the world seventy
years behind bars II could probably do
that and not half the time so you will
totally get to see Dora melash a
Throwdown during Black Panther the other
big comic book character is man ape he's
another antagonist that tries to take
black panthers thrown he started out as
one of their most fierce warriors then
plotted a coup failed and was exiled and
just continued to harass them over time
just became this big recurring villain
here's something that's really cool too
for those of you that are holding out
hope for Captain America stuff during
the movie actual Captain America stuff a
lot of these villains were also taken
down by Captain America himself but I
think it is going to be any victory to
be had in the film it'll be black
panthers victory it's his film it's sort
of like his first big outing in the
Marvel Universe it's not in someone
else's film so all hail the king of the
Marvel Universe
everybody wants his vibranium it's what
makes him richer than Tony Stark who we
can probably say is one of if not the
richest person in the Marvel Universe
that's why he doesn't bat an eyelash
when it comes to spending and making
toys for the Avengers funding all that
stuff so black panther himself could
also fund his own team of Avengers which
is why I think he's secretly helping out
Captain America on the DL while he's
hiding out from the government because
he's still an outlaw as the end of
Captain America Civil War for those of
you asking about the Infinity stones
what if the soul stone shows up in Black
Panther the only reason that I don't
think that it's going to show up during
Black Panther and it could is just
because the reality stone was stored on
earth and they said that no two gems
should be kept in the same place so that
would mean only one gem on earth at a
time and we have the mind stone in
vision right now meaning that the
reality gem is still with the collector
in the Nova Corps got the power stone so
that doesn't really address the more
mystical aspects of Black Panthers
abilities the Panther totem itself it
seems like so far based on what they
told us to
of all universe flows from a more
technological origin rather than a
mystical metahuman one even though there
are people with powers most of them are
obtained either through the Infinity
stone or through spider bytez
but even people like the vulture have a
more technological appearance it's just
the influence of Iron Man and the
success of that movie in that franchise
Robert Downey jr. on the rest of the
Marvel Universe all of the aesthetics
flow from him so it seems like most of
Black Panthers abilities flow from
technological sources but I do think
they'll weave in some of the mysticism
too but he typically eats herbs that
gives him his physical abilities that
makes him just as strong if not stronger
than Captain America that's not the only
thing that makes him a badass but he
also has access to the memories of all
the previous Black Panthers so that's
what they say king of the Dead Black
Panther they might address that during
the movie but they tend to brush over a
lot of the really weird stuff but there
was that line in Captain America Civil
War where he explained the death was not
the end - Black Widow after his father
had died I'm very sorry
in my culture this is not the end
suave tipping off point to rechart with
both ends in vast segments we lead you
into the green belt where get around
forever
I'm sorry peaceful thought out don't
fall so take that as you will but I
think that's them just acknowledging the
more mystical aspects of the Black
Panther comics so it's going to be great
they have ryan coogler he's a great
director did an awesome job with creed
the funny thing about Creed is that the
lead actress is actually playing
Valkyrie in Thor Ragnarok so it's like
all those people from Creed just came
into the Marvel Universe in different
places in by the way that actually
includes Sylvester Stallone here who has
a really small part in guardians of the
galaxy - even Michael B Jordan had the
sickest Fox Fantastic Four burn at
comic-con he's like thank God I'm
finally in the good Marvel Universe it
was such an offhanded comment but it
caught me by surprise like oh man he
said that in front of all those people
on camera but seriously though a lot of
you have asked me if Marvel will get the
rights to Fantastic Four back it's
totally possible I think that they would
try to use them in a big Avengers film
is like minor characters and then try to
weave them out into something bigger but
the only people that have said anything
about this are the directors who don't
have any control over those characters
they're not part of those discussions so
if we're anything about Fox characters
coming back to Marvel I will totally do
a video about it we can freak out but
let me know what do you guys most
excited for in the Black Panther movie I
know there'll be a lot of people who
just want to see how it connects to
infinity war because that'll be like our
first teeth but I am expecting
post-credit scenes from other movies
like Thor Ragnarok to sort of tee that
up too so there'll be a lot of infinity
war stuff happening in the background
through these other films so everybody
freaked out it's going to be great
what's going to happen next is there is
some more infinity wars that I want to
post this week there's some behind the
scenes spider-man stuff they've been
teasing a lot of stuff from the other
actors everyone's been saying a lot of
things so I will do new video sometimes
we can put I asked the new Star Wars
Episode eight there's new Game of
Thrones all kinds of Marvel and DC stuff
but I will say congratulations to the
new Spider Man giveaway winner Adam
Baker please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a Marvel video well you guys wait for
that next video you can click here to
learn all about the brand new Avengers
Square Enix game it's going to be crazy
and you can click here to listen to Tom
Holland talk about the new spider-man
suit thank you so much for watching
everybody high five I'll see you in the
next video
you